[Music]
today's speed round is brought to you by
verizon and the verizon 5g speed round
draft props edition chris let's get
right to it prop bets
and there are plenty of them that are
available it's a separate cottage
industry of the
legalized gambling not just on the
results of the games results on
the draft as well trey lance the over
under
for his draft position six and a half
before is a minus 230 favorite bet 230
to win
a hundred you've got him after i've got
him after
if it's before it's either the falcons
at four
or someone trading up with the dolphins
at six right that's the only way it
happens right
or the 49ers at three right right
they're taking justin fields yeah i mean
um
yeah i'm i'm gonna go with the over here
i think it's after six and a half i i
think
you know yeah in my heart of hearts you
know my thoughts i think the 49ers go
mac jones
i think the falcons go pits and i think
trey lance becomes a hot commodity
right there you know after that detroit
pick
where again they're a team would they
think about taking him i don't know
it's it it's interesting there but i
think right after that is when it gets
really interesting and he be
he becomes a hot commodity justin fields
the other quarterback that the 49ers are
considering
along with mac jones and trey lance his
over under is seven
and a half and before seven and a half
is the minus
140 favorite remember at one point he
was the
betting favorite to be the 49ers pick at
number three
so you've got slim chance i think of the
49ers at three
then where does the window open for him
before pick eight where is it really
this is trade-up scenario i think
if fields goes before pick number eight
don't you well i the the only thing
is like the lions at seven right
i think there is some thought out there
in the the nfl world that
you know because chris spielman's there
and him being a part of the organization
that he could be a part of this mix here
that justin fields could be the pick at
seven
i think that's the only only team i look
at
that i really think uh would take him in
the in
at least that was you know before that
seven and a half point there
then you know again you get into the
panthers and the broncos
i don't know i don't know again the
broncos are an interesting conversation
would they do that i
i i that's a tough one um but
but i would say if you're gonna make me
bet here i'm going with the over here
i'm gonna say he's on the board still
uh after after pick seven well and i
think that's why that dividing line is
seven and a half because the lions the
ohio state connections chris spume and
justin fields will that be enough
i'll tell you what though when i saw
michael parsons the penn state
linebacker in the mock draft that was
sent in to me
at seven to the line that makes sense
right the clouds parted the sun emerged
it all makes sense kneecap biter former
linebacker
spielman dan campbell very happy with
michael parsons yeah penny sewell
the over under for him is five and a
half and after
is now the favorite at -165 i think this
jamar chase to the bengals steam
has nudged sewell i know we talked about
him going forward to the falcons in the
pft
mock but the more popular choice
for sewell is seven to the lions yeah i
i mean the bengals thing is definitely
interesting that conversation there at
number five
but yeah you know you get into that
scenario kind of like what you just
talked about with the lions i mean again
it's knee it's knee cap biting it's
tough it's physical
like what would they do if penie sewell
and the micah parsons were on the board
there right i mean both of those fit the
mold
there's a true need for those both areas
on that football team
uh but i think with penne sewell yeah
i'm aaron
i'm airing on right now that the bangles
are going
jamar chase they're gonna go
full-fledged
you know fire show and make it about joe
burrow in the passing game and that
penny sewell stays on the board so we'll
see i'm going after though
sewell told me yesterday that when he
played madden as a kid he always played
with the detroit lions
so uh he he may end up being a detroit
lion although
why is that that's that's it i mean i
don't knock them down around for that
one why would you pick them of all the
teams
maybe because you know you want to
challenge and you find the worst team
you can
right when you beat the ai simulator but
uh yeah it was the lions
and uh but he also said that his
objective is to get drafted as high as
he possibly can and the highest for him
would be
the falcons at number four he gets that
he knows that the first three teams are
going quarterback
all right rashaan slater northwestern
tackle
before after nine and a half before his
a minus 130 favorite i got him cowboys
at 10
chris do you think he makes it to 10
or beyond i i i do i do i think there's
you know a scenario i guess where you
could look at him maybe going before
that point
right to where all right what if the
bangles
do take sewell right at five and then
what if the lions do want to still go
o-line like we talked about maybe that's
where rashaan slater comes off the board
i think most people think he is gonna be
the second o-lineman off the board
i think realistically though i don't see
the broncos taking him at nine
uh so i would say that he's gonna be on
the board after there and then you guard
into the
will the chargers or some of those teams
decide to
to help out their team by drafting the
big old lyman from northwestern
couple of alabama receivers just like
last year it was henry ruggs
and jerry judy this year it's devontae
smith and jalen waddle
who goes first between the two points
bet has
waddle as the minus 180
favorite to go before devonta smith i've
always thought waddle
would go first the pft mock draft has
smith 11 to the giants and waddle 12
to the eagles and there's just there's a
poetry to that i like that
but uh if i was going to bet i would say
waddle
is likely to go before smith what do you
think i i don't
i i'm the other way around i mean listen
i don't think it's crazy to think both
of these guys end up being picked
you know in the top 12. you know you
could see chase
waddle davonte smith all off the board i
think that's real devante smith to me is
a notch better than
jaylen waddle but again i know that uh
that's not like a hundred percent across
the board there's a lot of people in the
league that i think have your thought
that you know to that jalen waddle they
like him better
than devonta smith so i'm gonna go with
smith
you're going with waddle and i just i
have a hard time thinking that
two of the three receivers are going to
be gone in the top ten
i i just come away with that more times
than not looking at it like
i don't know which ones it'll be but two
out of those three
i think are definitely gone by the 10
and then that third one is going to be
gone i think somewhere between
11 and 15 for sure either way alabama
is looking at back-to-back years with
two receivers taken in the first round
before last year that only
ever happened three times lsu
dwayne bowen craig davis 2007.
ohio state ted ginn and anthony gonzalez
also
also 2007 and then 2001 miami santana
moss and reggie wayne
both uh in the first round so it
happened three times in history
before last year alabama and it's gonna
happen again this year
alabama yeah wherever they go they're
both going to be gone by the time the
round's over yeah and and
you know i'll add to like i think these
guys are
you know head and shoulders better than
the two receivers that came out last
year in the first round
i think there's a clear gap between
devonta smith and waddle compared to
judy and henry ruggs
you know those guys there was some flaws
in their game there's not really flaws
in either one of these games the only
flaw you could talk about
with either one of them really is just
hey waddlehead had an injury last year
so what all right i don't think that's
any big deal
devonte smith the weight thing that's it
there's nothing on film
at all to question there was things to
question about ruggs and judy
there's nothing physically about either
one of these two receivers from
alabama that you can come away going oh
i wonder about this i'm not sure about
that
they're pretty perfect micah parsons jc
horn parsons the penn state linebacker
horn the south carolina corner
who's drafted first between the two of
them horn is a minus 155
favorite what do you think of that one i
don't i mean
micah parson there's is in the to me the
small
club of elite defenders in the draft
jc horn is on the outside of that to me
but
you know again linebackers that are 6'3
plus 240 pounds and can run
the way micah parsons does and then he's
got the physicality to bring along with
they don't grow on trees
that's really a special combination so
uh i think michael parsons is will
definitely be off the board
in those first 12 picks for sure um and
you know mike
the corner i expect your tane to be off
the board before jc horn
yeah i agree with you i think parsons
goes before horn how about running backs
drafted in round one the over under is
1.5
under is a minus 200 favorite peter king
had nadia harris 24
to the steelers and travis atn number 30
to the buffalo bills if i recall
correctly and there's a very good chance
i don't you had
none right did you have no running backs
yeah i've got
i've got one i think i think i have
nadia harris 30 to the bills
in mind and look if the steelers do take
harris at 24 i think the door opens for
atn
number 30 to the bills but uh
i would i'm inclined to say under one
and a half
yes i am too without a doubt i mean i'm
really inclined
as you can tell to say zero to to a
degree
i mean i i am um now you know the bills
are
you know the steelers and the bills
those are the two teams you look at to
go
huh would they do it we know pittsburgh
is trying to change around their
attitude to their football team and play
a little bit of a different way on the
offensive side of the ball
the bills you know they're just looking
something
they need a presence a tailback they
haven't had it you know zach moss didn't
help out last year being a i believe he
was a third round pick
devin singletary's been solid but not
special you know so i i could see them
you know if maybe their board doesn't
line up i would expect
buffalo to be really thinking edge pass
rusher
you know that was an issue for them last
year they need somebody that could come
off the edge but
for them if they did go running back i'd
rather
be atn to buffalo just because hey
they're gonna we know they're gonna be
in the shotgun
and they're gonna try to throw the
football and atn is more of a space guy
in my opinion than a naji harris and he
can capitalize on more yards there to be
had that's where i would favor him
someone asked us yesterday on pftpm
when you would use a first round pick on
a running back and my response is simple
if you think it's earl campbell adrian
peterson
barry sanders emmitt smith and you're
willing to use him
accordingly otherwise address other
needs
and wait until round two three four five
six
seven or or undrafted to get your
running like you're you're right i mean
i
so like look is jot was josh jacobs
worth the first i wouldn't have taken no
no he wouldn't okay i mean that's i know
it's an interesting conversation
and i do think there's years where you
know hey a team
really is their biggest need is that
position and there is a player that's
worthy of that conversation there to be
picked in the 20s and running backs
where okay i can understand it
the raiders situation i can understand
it they had this old line they were
trying to play that style of football
but
yeah i'm with you i'd probably err i'm
not taking one either
all right let's go ahead and take a
break memorable draft
free falls that is the subject of this
wednesday pft live draft we'll do that
next right here we'll be right back
pro football talk is brought to you by
verizon built right for business
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports